on va tout de suite prendre la direction
de new york où l'ambassadrice américaine
auprès des nations unies est en train de
s'exprimer à l'occasion du conseil de
sécurité réuni en urgence
se dérouler en temps réel je félicite à
la capacité d écoute en ukrainien à
maintenir les six réacteurs sur alors
qu'ils étaient victimes d'une attaque
communiquer les informations régulateur
par ailleurs nous apprécions
le niveau de
noir remercier le régulateur ukrainien
merci pour sa communication à la isa
nous sommes fortement préoccupé
le fait que les opérateurs ukrainiens
font aujourd'hui leur travail sous une
contrainte énorme
l'attaquant russe hier
annie en danger elle le plus grand site
nucléaire d'europe
une action très dangereuse imprudente
qui a menacé la sécurité de citoyens
russes ukrainiens et européens européen
nous appelons la russie a retiré et ses
troupes du centre nucléaire afin de
permettre l'évacuation des plages
personnel des faits pour s'assurer que
les opérateurs et à un accès complet aux
cités soit en mesure de communiquer avec
les régulateurs
et permettre les opérateurs n'est une
rotation afin de s'assurer à ce que les
opérations de la centrale nucléaire il
soit sur
pied et les ingénieurs nucléaires
doivent avoir un accès
complet au 7e nucléaire afin d'évaluer
les dégâts en particulier sur les
canalisations
d'arrivée d'eau et pour évaluer du
potentiel détérioration supplémentaire
de la situation les installations
nucléaires ne peuvent pas à devenir
parties au conflit ne pas rentrer dans
ce conflit ce mal électricité fiable est
essentiel pour sept centrales nucléaires
tout comme les groupes électrogènes des
corridors des couloirs de transit sur
doivent être maintenus la russie doit
cesser toute utilisation de la force qui
pourrait mettre en danger on est l 15
réacteurs
actifs en ukraine ou interférer avec la
capacité de l'ukraine de maintenir la
sécurité et la sûreté
trente sept centrales nucléaires et de
la population adjacentes les etats unis
restent des prix préoccupe et sans le
fait que les forces russes qui contrôle
le site de tchernobyl n'ont pas autorisé
aux opérateurs de faire une rotation
depuis la semaine dernière
il s'agit d'un comportement très
responsable qui entraîne de fortes
préoccupations pour la poursuite des
opérations sur des deux sites
par ailleurs nous exhortons tous les
pays à soutenir le
directeur général de la loi dans cet
effort pour trouver un accord à l'avenir
afin de s'assurer afin d'assurer la
sécurité nucléaire et éviter une
catastrophe nucléaire en ukraine
derniers jours nous avons observé
l'impact dévastateur les impacts
dévastateurs de la guerre de choix de
poutine sur le peuple ukrainien
nations unies ont signalé que l'invasion
russe a achevé a entraîné
cinq cent mille enfants
de 500 enfants des réfugiés
a énormément deux soldats russes irina
qui s'endort
la russie détruit des infrastructures
publiques
ainsi les ukrainiens n'ont pas accès à
l'eau n'ont pas accès au gaz pour bois
et pour se réchauffer en plein hiver
l'impact humanitaire de ces destructions
sera significatif
cent quarante et une nation dans le
monde ont appelé
le président poutine et c'est cette
guerre brutale non justifiée non
provoquées
le président poutine n'écoute pas ça
s'appelle claire mais nous venons de
voir une nouvelle étape dans l' escalade
qui représente une menace directe pour
toute l'europe et pour le monde entier
à mon homologue russe ce conseil a
besoin de réponses nous avons besoin de
vous entendre dire cela ne se reproduira
plus comme notre collègue britannique
vient de l'éthique nous vous exhortons à
retirer vos troupes et vos équipements
militaires d'ukraine nous vous exhortons
à respecter les frontières à une géniale
respecter son peuple et respecter la
charte des nations unies nous vous
exhortons de respecter vos propres
soldats afin de ne pas les envoyer dans
une ferme de mener une guerre injuste ou
les envoyer dans une mission suicide
contre une centrale nucléaire
nous exhortons la russie
respecter ses engagements vis-à-vis du
droit international le monde exige que
la russie respecte le droit
international humanitaire qui interdit
le ciblage intentionnelle des civils et
les infrastructures civiles
permettent aux agences humanitaires
d'avoir accès en sécurité aux personnes
ayant besoin d'être
les etats-unis et ses partenaires ont
demandé la tenue d'une réunion ce matin
sur la situation humanitaire en ukraine
nous soutenons le travail urgent menées
par les organisations humanitaires
soutenons la proposition
la création de couloirs permettant
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire le
président poutine pour moi mettre un
terme à cette catastrophe humanitaire en
stoppant cette guerre est en jeu c'est
sans ses attaques
atroce contre le peuple ukrainien
masta monsieur poutine doit cesser cette
folie dès aujourd'hui
il faut certes entre deux soins calme
les forces russes sont à présent à 20
miles âge d'un site nucléaire très grand
donc le danger reste présent nous avons
évité de très près une catastrophe
l'année dernière
la communauté internationale doit être
unanimes et exigé à ce que les forces
russes arrêtent leurs attaques
dangereuses et comme je l'aï déjà dit
par le passé le peuple ukrainien
comptent sur nous
et nous ne devons pas les abandonner
merci
la parole à la france madame la
présidente
je remercie monsieur grossit et madame
di carlo pour leur intervention la
france est gravement préoccupés des
risques pour la sûreté la sécurité et
les garanties nucléaires qui résultent
de l'invasion russe
c'est pourquoi avec ses partenaires elle
a demandé que le conseil de sécurité se
réunisse en urgence
le 24 février les forces russes sont
entrés dans la zone de tchernobyl
l'équipe d'exploitation de la centrale a
été retenu et réquisitionné par les
militaires russes le 27 février une
forte détonation a été enregistré près
d'un centre d'entreposage de déchets à
kiev
ce matin un incendie s'est déclaré dans
la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'europe à la suite de la tacc rue
comme l'a indiqué le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères la
france condamne fortement cette atteinte
à l'intégrité d'une structure nucléaire
dont il faut garantir la sécurité
les conséquences d'un accident nucléaire
résultant de l'agression militaire
commises par la russie contre l'ukraine
sont potentiellement dévastatrice pour
la santé humaine et pour l'environnement
en 2009 la russie a approuvé avec le
reste de la conférence générale de
l'aiea la décision selon laquelle toute
attaque et menace armée contre des
installations nucléaires consacrée à des
fins pacifiques
constitue une violation des principes de
la charte des nations unies du droit
international et du statut de lagence la
compétence du conseil de sécurité dans
cette circonstance étaient également
établis par les résolutions de la
conférence générale de l'aiea
la russie doit cesser immédiatement ses
activités illégales et dangereuses
afin de rétablir le contrôle des
autorités ukrainiennes sur toutes les
installations et matières nucléaires à
l'intérieur des frontières
internationalement reconnues de
l'ukraine
la russie doit également autoriser un
accès régulier sans entrave du personnel
des installations pour garantir la
poursuite de leur exploitation en toute
sécurité
nous appelons au plein respect de la
convention sur la sûreté nucléaire et
des autres conventions pertinentes
la france soutient les efforts du
directeur général de l'aiea pour la
surveillance continue de la sûreté et de
la sécurité les installations nucléaires
en ukraine en contact étroit avec les
autorités ukrainiennes nous demandons au
directeur général de l'aeia d'utiliser
tous les instruments de lagence pour
soutenir les efforts de l'ukraine afin
d'assurer la sûreté et la sécurité de
toutes les installations du pays à cet
égard la france apporte son soutien à la
proposition du directeur général de
l'aiea pour la négociation d'engagement
entre les parties au conflit armé en
ukraine afin d'assurer le respect des
sept principes qu'il a établie lors du
des gouverneurs du 2 mars 2022 sur les
implications de la situation en ukraine
en matière de sûreté de sécurité et de
garantie nucléaire
la france réitère enfin son soutien
indéfectible à l'indépendance à la
souveraineté et à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine dans ses
frontières internationalement reconnues
depuis le 24 février nous avons été
témoins du coût humain dévastateur de
l'agression russe une cessation
immédiate des hostilités et
l'application stricte du droit
international humanitaire est urgente
c'est pourquoi avec le mexique la france
porte une résolution dans cet objectif
afin de mettre un terme au drame
humanitaire qui se joue sous nos yeux
ici comme ailleurs le conseil de
sécurité doit assumer toutes ses
responsabilités
je vous remercie
les interventions de l'ambassadrice
américaine auprès des nations unies
suivi de l'ambassadeur de france auprès
des nations unies